the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to continue our
discussion of parametric curves I have
to tell you about arc length and let me
remind you where we left off last time
this is parametric curves continued last
time we talked about the parametric
representation for the circle or one of
the parametric representations for the
circle which was this one here and first
we noted that this does parameterize as
we say the circle that satisfies the
equation for the circle and it's traced
counterclockwise the picture looks like
this here's the circle and it starts out
here at T equals zero and it gets up to
here it at time T equals PI over two so
so now I have to talk to you about arc
length in this parametric form and the
results should be the same as arc length
around the circle or narrowly and we
start out with this basic differential
relationship D s squared is DX squared
plus dy squared and then I'm going to
divide by take the square root divided
by DT so the rate of change with respect
to t of s is going to be the square root
well maybe i'll write it without
dividing just write it as d s so this
would be DX dt the quantity squared plus
dy DT the quantity squared DT so this is
what you get formally from this equation
if you take its square root and you
divide by DT squared in the inside the
square root and you multiply by DT
outside so that those cancel and this is
the formal connection between the two
we'll be saying just a few more words in
a few minutes about how to make that
sense of that rigorously all right so
that's that's the the set of formulas
for the infinitesimal the differential
of arc length and so to figure it out I
have to differentiate X with respect to
T and remember X is up here it's defined
by a cosine T so it's derivative is
minus a sine T and similarly dy DT is a
cosine T all right and so I can plug
this in and I get the arc length element
which is the square root of minus a sine
T squared plus a cosine T squared DT
which just becomes the square root of a
squared DT or a DT
now I was about to divide by T let me do
that now we can also write the rate of
change of arc length with respect to T
and that's a in this case and this gets
interpreted as the speed of the of the
particle going around so not only let me
trade these two guys not only do we have
the the direction is counterclockwise
but we also have that the speed is if
you like its uniform its its constant
speed and the the rate is a so that's
dsdt traveling around and that means
that we can play around with the speed
and I just want to point out so the
standard thing which you'll have to get
used to and this is a standard
presentation you'll see this everywhere
in your physics classes in your other
math classes if you want to change the
speed so a new speed going around this
would be if I set up the equations this
way now I'm tracing around the same
circle but the speed is going to turn
out to be if you figure it out it there
will be an extra factor of K so it'll be
a times K that's what will work out to
be the speed it provided K is positive
and a is positive so we're making these
conventions that the constants that
we're using or positive all right now
that's that's the first and most basic
example the one that comes up constantly
now let me just make those those
comments about notation that I wanted to
make and and we've been treating these
square differentials here for a little
while and I just want to pay attention a
little bit more carefully to these
manipulations and what's allowed and
what's not and what's justified and
what's not so the basis for this was
this approximate calculation that we had
that Delta s squared was Delta x squared
plus Delta Y squared this is how we how
we justified the arc length formula
before and let me just show you that the
formula that I have up here this basic
formula for arc length in the parametric
form follows just as the other one did
and now I'm going to do it slightly more
rigorously I do the division really in
disguise before I take the limit of the
infinitesimal so all I'm really doing is
I'm doing this dividing through by this
and sorry this is still approximately
equal so I'm not dividing by something
that's 0 or infinite s 1 dividing by
something nonzero and here I have Delta
X delta T squared plus Delta Y delta T
the quantity squared and then in the
limit I have D s DT is equal to this
square root of this guy or if you like
the square of it
okay so so though it's legal to divide
by something that's almost 0 and then
take the limit as we go to 0 this is
really what derivatives are all about
that we get a limit here as the
denominator goes to 0 because the
numerator is going to 0 - all right so
that's the notation and now I want to
warn you maybe just a little bit about
about misuses if you like of the
notation we don't do absolutely
everything this way this expression that
came up with the squares you should
never write it
as this okay
this this put it on the board but very
quickly carry her never okay don't don't
do that it's it's we use these square
differentials but we don't do it with
these ratios here but there was another
place which is slightly confusing looks
very similar where we did use the square
of the differential in a denominator I
just want to point out to you that it's
different it's not the same and it is
okay and that was this one Swoopes this
thing here okay this is a second
derivative it's something else and it's
got a dt squared in the denominator so
it looks rather similar but what this
represents is the quantity D over DT
squared and you can see the squares came
in and squared the two the two
expressions and then there's also an x
over here all right so that's legal
that's those are notations that we do
use and we can even calculate this it
has a perfectly good meaning it's the
same as the derivative with respect to T
of the derivative of X which we already
know was minus sign sorry a sign t I
guess alright not not this example but
the previous one right up here so the
derivative is this and so I can
differentiate a second time and I get
minus a cosine T alright so that's a
perfectly legal operation everything in
there makes sense just don't use that
there's another really unfortunate thing
right which is that the two creeps and
funny places right with sines right you
have sine squared we it would be out
here it comes up here for some strange
reason you know this is just because
typographers are lazy or somebody
somewhere in the history of mathematical
typography decided to let the to migrate
it would be like putting the two over
here it's you know there's there's in
consistency in mathematics right and
we're not we're not perfect and people
just develop these notations so we have
to live with them
all right the ones that people accept as
conventions all right now the next
example that I want to give you is just
slightly different it will be a non
constant speed parameterization here X
is 2 sine T and Y is say cosine T and
let's keep track of what this one does
now this is a skill which you're I'm
going to ask you about quite a bit and
it's one of several skills you'll have
to connect this with some kind of
rectangular equation an equation for x
and y and we'll be doing a certain
amount of this today in another context
right here to see the pattern we know
that the relationship we're going to
want to use is that sine squared plus
cosine squared is equal to 1 so in fact
the right thing to do here is to take
one quarter of x squared plus y squared
and that's going to turn out to be sine
squared T plus cosine squared T which is
1 so there's the equation here's the
rectangular equation for this parametric
curve and the this describes an ellipse
now that's not the only information that
we can get here the other information
that we can get is this qualitative
information of where we start where
we're going the direction it starts out
I claim at t equals zero that's when T
is equal to zero this is a 2 sine 0
cosine 0 right 2 sine 0 cosine 0 is
equal to the point 0 comma 1 so it
starts up up here at 0 comma 1 and then
the next little place so this is this is
one thing that certainly you'll want to
do T equals PI over 2 is maybe the next
easy points to plot and that's going to
be a 2 sine PI over 2
cosine PI over 2 and that's just 2 comma
0 and so that's over here somewhere this
is 2 comma 0 and we know it travels
along the ellipse and we know the minor
axis is 1 in the major axis is 2 so it's
it's doing this alright so this is what
happens at T equals 0 this is this is
where we are at T equals PI over 2 and
it continues all the way around etc to
the rest of the ellipse right this is
the direction right so this one happens
to be clockwise all right now let's keep
track of its speed let's keep track of
the speed and also the the arc length so
the speed is the square root of the
derivatives here that would be 2 cosine
T squared plus sine T squared all right
and the arc length is what well if we
want to go all the way around we need to
know that that takes a total of 2 pi so
0 to 2 pi and then we have to integrate
DS which is this expression or D SD T DT
so that's the square root of 4 cosine
squared T plus sine squared T DT
all right now the bad news if you like
is that this is not an elementary
integral in other words no matter how
long you try to figure out how to
anti-differentiate this expression no
matter how many substitutions you try
you will fail all right that's the bad
news the good news is this is not an
elementary interval in integral sorry
it's not an elementary integral which
means that this is the answer to a
question not something that you have to
work on so if somebody asks you for this
arc length you stop here okay that's the
answer so it's actually better than it
looks and we'll try to I mean I'm not I
don't expect you to know already what
all the integrals are that are
impossible and which ones are hard and
which ones are easy so we'll try to
coach you through when you face these
things it's it's not so easy to decide
I'll give you a few clues but okay so
this is the this is the arc length now I
want to move on to the to the last thing
that we did last type of thing that we
did last time which is the surface area
and yeah question
the question this is good question the
question is when you draw the ellipse do
you not take into account what T is the
answer is that this is in disguise
what's going on here is we have a
trouble with plotting in the plane
what's really happening so in other
words we're kind of in trouble so I
wasn't the point is that we have two
functions of T naught 1 X of T and Y of
T so one thing that I could do if I plot
things in the plane in other words the
main point to make here is that we're
not talking about the situation Y is a
function of X we're out of that realm
now we're somewhere in a different part
of the universe in our thought and you
should drop this point of view all right
so this depiction is not Y is a function
of X well you know that's obvious
because because there are two values
here as opposed to one so we're in
trouble with that and we have this
background parameter that's exactly why
we're using it this parameter T so that
we can depict the entire curve and deal
with as one thing so I since I can't
really draw it and since T is nowhere on
the map you should sort of imagine it is
time and there's some kind of trajectory
which is traveling around and then I
just labeled a couple of the places if
somebody asked you to draw a picture of
this well I'll tell you exactly where
you need the picture in just one second
all right
it's going to come up right now in
surface area but otherwise if somewhat
nobody asked you to you don't even have
to put down T equals zero and T equals
PI over 2 here because nobody nobody
demanded it of you yeah another question
ah yeah so very another very good
question which is exactly connected to
this picture so how is it that we're
going to use the picture and how is it
we're going to use the notion of the T
the question was why is this for from T
equals 0 to T equals 2pi that does use
the T information on this on this
diagram the point is we do know that T
starts here this is PI over 2 this is a
PI this is 3 PI over 2 and this is
two pi when you go all the way around
once it's going to come back to itself
these are periodic functions a period
two pi and they come back to themselves
exactly at two pi and so that's why we
know in order to get around once we need
to we need to go from zero to two pi and
that's the same thing it's going to come
up with surface area right now we're
going to that's going to be the issue is
what range of T we're going to need when
we compute the surface area in a
question what you might be asked is
what's the rectangular equation for a
parametric curve so that would be 1/4 x
squared plus y squared equals 1 and then
you might be asked plotted well that
would be a picture of the ellipse okay
that's those are types of questions
they're legal questions
the question is do I need to know any
specific formulas any formulas that you
know and remember will help you they may
be of limited use I would I'm not going
to ask you to memorize anything except I
guarantee you that the circle is going
to come up not not the ellipse the
circle will come up everywhere in your
life so at least at MIT your life at MIT
we're very round here all right yeah
another question I'm just a tiny bit
confused back to the basics this is more
of a question from yesterday I guess but
when you have your original D s squared
equals DX squared plus dy squared and
then you integrate that to get arc
length yes it's how are you the integral
has the X's and be wise so how are you
just integrating with respect to DX okay
the question is how are we just
integrating with respect to X so this is
a question which goes back to last time
and what is it with arc length so so I'm
going to I'm going to have to answer
that question in connection with what we
did today so this is this is a subtle
question but I want you to realize that
this is actually an important conceptual
step here so Shh everybody listen right
if you're representing one-dimensional
objects which are curves maybe in space
or in two dimensions when you're keeping
track of arc length you're going to have
to have an integral which is with
respect to some variable but that
variable you get to pick and we're
launching now into this variety of
choices of variables with respect to
which you can you can represent
something now there are some
disadvantages on the circle to
representing things with respect to the
variable X because there are two points
on the circle here on the other hand you
actually can succeed with half the
circle so you can figure out the arc
length of that way and then you can set
it up as an integral DX but you can also
set it up as an integral with respect to
any parameter you want
and the uniform parameter is perhaps the
easiest one this one is perhaps the
easiest one and all of the so now the
thing that's strange about this
perspective and I'm going to make this
point later in the in a lecture as well
is that the letters X and y you should
as I say you should drop this notion
that Y is a function of X this is what
we're throwing away at this point what
we're thinking of is you can describe
things in terms of any coordinate you
want you just have to say what each one
is in terms of the others and this these
x and y over here are where we are in
the Cartesian coordinate system they're
not and in this case they're functions
of some other variable some other
variable so they're each function so the
letters X and Y just changed on you they
mean something different Y is not X is
no longer the variable it's the function
all right well you're going to have to
get used to that that's because we run
out of letters and we kind of want to
use all of them the way we want I'll say
some more about that later all right so
now I want to do this surface area
example I'm going to just take the
surface area of the ellipsoid the
surface of the ellipsoid formed by
revolving this previous example which
was example 2 around the y-axis alright
so I want to set up that surface area
integral here for you now I remind you
that the area element looks like this if
you're revolving around the y-axis that
means you're going around this way and
you have some curve in this case it's
this piece of an ellipse if you sweep it
around you're going to get what's called
an ellipsoid
and there's a little chunk here that
you're wrapping around and the important
thing you need besides this des this
this arc length piece over here is the
distance to the axis so that's this
horizontal distance here I'll draw it in
another color and that horizontal
distance now has a name and this is
again the virtue of this coordinate
system the T is something else this has
a name this distance has a name this
distance is called X and it even has a
formula its formula is a two sine T in
terms of T so the full formula for the
integral here is I have to take the
circumference when I spin this thing
around in this little arc length element
so I have here 2 pi times 2 sine T
that's the that's the X variable here
and then I have here DS which is kind of
a mess so unfortunately I don't quite
have room for it plan ahead square root
of 4 cosine squared T plus sine squared
T is that what it was
DT all right I guess I squeezed it in
here all right so that was the arc
length which I recopy from this board
above here that was the DS piece sorry
this it's this whole thing including the
DT all right that's the answer except
for one thing what else do we need we
don't just need the integrand this is
half of setting up an integral the other
half of setting up an integral is the
limits we need specific limits here
otherwise we don't have a number that we
can get out so we now have to think
about what the limits are and maybe
somebody can see it has something to do
with this diagram of the ellipse over
here can somebody guess what it is 0 to
PI well that was quick Wow
all right that's it because we go from
the top to the bottom but we don't want
to continue around we don't want to go
from zero to 2pi because that would be
duplicating what we're going to get when
we spin around all right and we know
that we start at zero it's interesting
because it descends when you change
variables to think of it in terms of the
Y variable it's going the opposite way
but anyway just one piece of this is
what we want all right
so that's that's the set up and now I
claim that this is actually a doable
integral however it's long I'm going to
spare you I'll just tell you how you
would get started you would use the
substitution U is equal to cosine T and
then the D U is going to be minus sine T
DT but then unfortunately there's a lot
more there's another trig substitution
with some other multiple of the cosine
and so forth so it goes on and on if you
want to check it yourself you can all
right there's another there's an inverse
trig substitution which isn't compatible
with this one all right but it but it
can be done calculated all right
in elementary charms all right yeah
another question so if you get this on
an exam I'm going to have to coach you
through it either I'm going to have to
tell you don't evaluate it or you're
going to have to work really hard or
here's the first step and then the next
step is keep on going or something I
have to give you all you have to give
you some cues because it's quite long
this is way too long for an exam this
particular one okay it's not too long
for problem set this is where I would
leave you off if I were if I were giving
it to you on a problem set just to give
you an idea of the order of magnitude
whereas one of the ones that I did
yesterday I wouldn't even give you on a
problem set it was so long okay all
right
so now our next job is to move on to
polar coordinates now polar coordinates
involve the geometry of circles as I
said we really love circles here we're
very round just as I love zero the rest
of the institute loves circles so we're
going to do that right now
all right what we're going to talk about
now is polar coordinates which are set
up in the following way it's a way of
describing the points in the plane here
is a point in the plane and here's what
we think of as the usual XY axes and now
this point is going to be described by a
different pair of coordinates different
pair of numbers namely the distance to
the origin and the second parameter here
second number here is this angle theta
which is the angle of Ray from origin
with the horizontal axis
so that's what it is in language and you
should put this in quotation marks
because it's not a perfect match all
right this isn't this is geometrically
what you should always think of but the
technical details involve dealing
directly with formulas the first formula
is the formula for X and this is the
fundamental these two are the
fundamental ones namely X is our cosine
theta
the second formula is the formula for Y
which is our sine theta so these are the
unambiguous definitions of polar
coordinates this is this is it and this
is the thing from which all other almost
correct statements almost follow but
this is the one you should trust always
this is the unambiguous statement all
right so let me give you an example of
something that's close to being a good
formula and it's certainly useful in its
way namely you can think of R as being
the square root of x squared plus y
squared right that's easy enough to
derive it's the distance to the origin
that's pretty obvious and the formula
for theta which you can also derive
which is that it's the inverse tangent
of Y divided by X however let me just
warn you that these formulas are
slightly ambiguous so somewhat ambiguous
in other words you can't just apply them
blindly you actually have to look at a
picture in order to get them right in
particular our could be plus or minus
here and when you take the inverse
tangent
there's an ambiguity between it's the
same as the inverse tangent of - why / -
X so these minus signs are a plague on
your existence
and you're not going to get a completely
unambiguous answer out of these formulas
without real ah without paying attention
to the diagram on the other hand the
formula up in the box there always works
alright so when people mean polar
coordinates they always mean that and
then they have conventions which
sometimes match things up with with with
the formulas over on the on this next
board all right let me let me give you
various examples here first but first
well maybe maybe first I should I should
draw the two coordinate systems so the
coordinate system that we're used to is
the rectangular coordinate system and
maybe I'll draw it in orange and green
here so so these are the coordinate
lines
y equals 0 y equals 1 y equals 2 that's
how the coordinate system works and over
here we have the rest of the coordinate
system and this is the way we're
thinking of x and y now we're no longer
thinking of Y as a function of X and X
as a function of Y we're thinking of X
is a label of a place in the plane and Y
as a label of a place in the plane so
here we have a equals 0 x equals 1 x
equals 2 etc here's x equals negative 1
so forth alright so that's what the
that's what the the rectangular
coordinate system looks like and now I
should draw the other coordinate system
that we have which is this guy here well
close enough and these guys here kind of
this bullseye or target operation and
this one is say theta is equal to PI
over 2 this is theta equals 0 this is
theta equals negative PI over 4 for
instance so I've just labeled for you
three of the Rays on this
diagram it's kind of like a radar screen
and then in pink this is maybe R equals
to the radius to and inside is R equals
1 right so it's a different coordinate
system for the plane and again the
letter R represents measuring how far we
are from the origin the rather low the
theta represents something about the
angle which way we're on and they're
just two different variables and this is
a very different kind of coordinate
system
okay so our main job is just to get used
to this for now you will be using this a
lot in 1802 it's very useful in physics
and our job is just to just to get get
started with it and so let's try a few
examples here tons of examples we'll
start out very slow if you have XY
equals 1 comma minus 1 that's a point in
the plane I can draw that pick at that
point it's down here right this is
negative 1 and this is 1 and here's my
point 1 negative 1 I can figure out what
the representative is it is of this in
polar coordinates so in polar
coordinates there are actually a bunch
of choices here first of all I'll tell
you one choice if I start with the angle
horizontally I wrap all the way around
that would be to this this Ray here
let's do it in green again all right I
labeled actually as minus PI over 4 but
another way of looking at it is that
it's it's it's this angle here so that
would be R equals square root of 2 theta
equals 7 PI over 4 all right so that's
one possibility of the angle and the
distance I know the distance is square
root of 2 that's not hard another way of
looking at it is the way which was
suggested when I labeled this with a
negative angle and that would be R
equals square root of 2 theta equals
minus PI over 4 and these are both legal
these are perfectly legal
representatives and that's what I meant
by saying that it that these
representations over here are somewhat
ambiguous there's more than one answer
to this question of what the polar
representation is a third possibility
which is even more dicey but also legal
is R equals minus square root of 2 theta
equals 3 PI
over for now what that corresponds to
doing is going around to here we're
pointing out 3/4 pi direction but then
going negative square root of 2 distance
we're going backwards so we're landing
in the same place so this is also legal
yeah the radiuses have to be positive
because they represent a distance from
the origin but the question is don't the
radiuses have to be positive because
they represent a distance to the origin
the answer is I lied to you here all of
these things that I said are wrong
except for this which is the rule for
what polar coordinates mean okay so it's
maybe plus or minus the distance is that
is is what it is always ok gotta be yeah
I don't I try not to lie to you too much
but but I do succeed now now let's let's
let's do a little bit more practice here
there are some easy examples which I
will run through very quickly R equals a
we already know this is a circle and the
three theta equals a constant is array
however this involves an implicit
assumption which I want to point out to
you so this is example 3 theta is equal
to constant is array but this implicitly
assumes 0 is less than or equal to R is
less than infinity if you really wanted
to allow minus infinity less than R less
than infinity in this example you would
get a line gives the whole line all
right it gives everything behind so you
go out on some array you go backwards on
that ray and you get the whole line
through the origin both ways if you
allow
are going to minus infinity as well so
the typical convention so here are the
typical conventions and you will see
people assume this without even telling
you so you need to watch out for it the
typical conventions are certainly this
one which is a nice thing to do pretty
much all the time although not all the
time most of the time and then you might
have theta ranging from minus PI to PI
so in other words symmetric around zero
or another very popular case choices is
this one theta greater than or equal to
zero and strictly less than two pi so
these are the these are the two typical
ranges in which all of these variables
are chosen but not always you'll find
that it's not consistent all right let's
do as I said our job is to get used to
this and I need to work up to some
slightly more complicated examples some
of which I'll give you on next Tuesday
but let's let's do a few more so example
I guess this is example for example for
I'm going to take Y equals 1 that's
awfully simple in in rectangular
coordinates but interestingly you might
conceivably want to deal with it in
polar coordinates if you do so here's
how you make the translation this
translation is not so terrible what you
do is you plug in y equals R sine theta
that's all you have to do and so that's
going to be equal to 1 and that's going
to give us our polar equation the polar
equation is R equals 1 over sine theta
there it is
and let's draw a picture of it so here's
a picture of the line y equals 1 and now
we see that if we take our rays going
out from here they collide with the line
at various lengths so if you take a fit
and angle theta here there will be a
distance R corresponding that and you'll
hit this in exactly one spot for each
theta you'll have a different radius and
it's a variable radius it's given by
this formula here and so to trace this
line out you actually have to realize
that there's one more thing involved
which is the possible range of theta
again when you're doing integrations
you're going to need to know those
limits of integration so you're going to
need to know this the range here goes
from theta equals 0 that's sort of when
it's out at infinity that's when the
denominator is 0 here and it goes all
the way to PI swing around just one half
turn so the range here is 0 less than
theta less than pi yeah question the
question is is it typical to express R
as a function of theta or vice versa or
doesn't matter the answer is that for
the purposes of this course we're almost
always going to be writing things in
this form R as a function of theta and
you can do whatever you want this turns
out to be what we'll be doing in this
course exclusively it's it's it's as
you'll see when we get to other examples
it's that it's the traditional sort of
thing to do when you're thinking about
observing a planet or something like
that you're you're observing it's the
ant you see the angle and then you see
how you guess how far away it is so it's
but it's but it's not necessarily you
could the formulas are often easier this
way for the examples that we have
because it's usually a trig function of
theta whereas the other way it would be
an inverse
trig function so it's an ugly or
expression all right as you can see the
real reason is that we choose the thing
that's easier to deal with all right so
now let me give you a slightly more
complicated example of the same type
where we we use a shortcut this is a
this is a standard example and it comes
up a lot and so this is an off-center
circle a circle is really easy to
describe but not necessarily if this if
the center is on the is on the rim of
the circle all right so that's a
different problem now let's do this with
a circle of radius a so this is this is
the point a comma 0 and this is 2a comma
0
and actually if you know these two
numbers you'll be able to remember the
result of this calculation which you'll
do about five or six times and then
finally you'll memorize it during 1802
when you will need it a lot so this is a
standard calculation here so what the
furthest starting place is the
rectangular equation and we're going to
pass to the polar representation the
rectangular representation is X minus a
squared plus y squared is equal to a
squared so this is a circle centered at
a comma 0 of radius a and now the if you
like the slow way of doing this would be
to plug in x equals sorry x equals R
cosine theta y equals R sine theta the
way I did in this first step and that
works perfectly well but I'm going to do
it more quickly than that because I can
sort of see in advance how it's going to
work I'm just going to expand this out
all right and now I see the a Squared's
cancel and not only that but x squared
plus y squared is R squared so this
becomes R squared that's x squared plus
y squared minus 2ax is equal to zero all
right
the R came from the fact that R squared
is equal to x squared plus y squared all
right so I'm doing this the rapid way
you can do it by plugging in as I said R
equals so now I'm now that I've
simplified it I'm actually am going to
use that procedure I'm going to plug in
so here I have R squared minus 2a R
cosine theta equals 0 I just plugged in
for X as I said I could have done that
at the beginning I just simplified first
and now this is the same thing as R
squared is equal to 2a R cosine theta
and we're almost done there's a boring
part of this equation which is R equals
0 and then there's if I divided by R
there's the interesting part of the
equation which is this so this is for R
equals 0 which is already included in
that equation anyway all right so I'm
allowed to divide by R because in the
case of R equals 0 this is represented
anyway question R equals 0 is just one
case that is it that it's the union of
these two it's both are both are
possible so R equals 0 is one point on
it and this is all of it ok so we can
just ignore this alright so now I want
to say one more important thing you need
to understand the range of this so so
wait a second and we're going to figure
out the range here the range is very
important because otherwise you'll never
be able to integrate using this
representation here so this is the
representation but notice when theta
is equal to zero we're out out here at
2a that's consistent and that's actually
how you remember this fact or 2a here is
if you remember this picture and where
you land when theta is equal to zero
right so that's the theta equals zero
part but now as I tip up like this you
see that when we get to vertical we're
done with the circle it's gotten shorter
and shorter and shorter and at theta
equals PI over two we're down at zero
because that's cosine of PI over two is
zero so it swings up like this and it
gets up to PI over two similarly we
swing down like this and then we're done
so the range is minus PI over two is
less than theta is less than PI over two
or if you want to throw in the R equals
zero case you can throw in this this is
repeating if you like at the ends right
so so this is the range of this circle
and let's see next time we'll figure out
area in polar coordinates